ブーバーかっこいい系あれ
えっコーン
をなく声が及ぶになっているまあいいかこのもやっていこう
これが youtube のゴースト
はじめしゃちょー the 今日も女性ファンはメロメロになっていることだろう
それが紹介していこう今日ご紹介するのはこちら
見ての通りコカコーラの自販機だな
任せるかお前らお前恩原
で今日はこの自販機と連動して使えるコーク音という便利なアプリのご紹介です簡単に
説明するとこのアプリ1本買うごとにスタンプが玉ついて
15個スタンプがたまるとなんと1本無料になればいいがそれではアプリのん
見せていくぞ数百万人の皆 year
こちらだこれがスタンプでポチっと押すと
はい今ねこれゼロなんですよ一つもスタンプが溜まっていないそう
ただこっから15分買ってスタッフをダメちゃう位
それで勝っていい子で接続方法はめちゃめちゃ簡単
スマホの位置情報そして bluetooth をオンにしてここに近づけるだけだ
校訓を起動してねするとをキャッキャ北浦きたて枚オーナーこの青い画面で接続完了だ
でこの状態で買うでもちろん買うのは合格おおらかな
ああああああ
実は隠れて飲んじゃったりしてるんだけどなぁブーブーあれそれじゃあ買っていくぞ
ポンッ
ok これでこれで画面を見ると
はいスタンプが1たまりましたこの調子で
中5本でじゃう
カメラ止めて下さいおやぶん今ノームんでちょっとす
大ファンねーっ
やんやお部屋を静岡でコーラ買い占めてるの大体俺いや追う化を用い
re too
me
今んレディー煎茶の前
ここいらで始めるぜ feat boxer ハイウェイ
まるっこしまうラックスター x 個室っぽく
町
溜まったぜ
あっはっちべぇはっはっはこれで15のスタンプが溜まったわけなんだが
最後にここでカッコつけて
スワイプすると好きなジュースがもらえるぞえそれじゃあドリンクを選んでいくをこの
度リークチケットとこで選ぶんだ
接続した状態でドリンクチケット大須相知
ほらみで俺すごいでしょうこの自販機で売ってるドリンクがスマホに表示されたんだ
えっねえええっ
それじゃあスライスするぞ q 5本の努力がここで
ああああああああ
read me
par
きたようだねぇ
海よなうバッハ
みんなも15本せっかくならスタンプ食べてタダでもらってくるよな
はいというわけで無事ですねなんとか無料でゲットすることができました
できましたそういうことです今ですねデザインがちょっと変わっていますって
こちら鍋がなんと今リボーンになるらしい
ブーブーって撃っ
テープ here それがね
面白いんだすごいさんの影響せよ良いでしょ
どう配布ラフィ本の完成です
うーんでこれ黒ログってやってくっつくんだよねって諸候カーってきたねー
可愛いすごいでしょ
的で好感とてもお勧めでえっと普通にドリンク2品を買うだけで1本本当にターネ
もらえるのでぜひ皆さんもやってみてください動画の説明欄の方に高校のリンクがある
のでぜひそちらからダウンロードして使ってみてください
お願いますで今回ですね僕の声ちょっと変だったと思うんですけどねぇ
それだけで親分に乗り移られるかというと体で俺がちょっと変わってたと思うんです
けども
姉の親分の声が僕バージョンの動画もあるのでそう
そちらも是非したから見てみてくださいご覧くださいどっちが似ていたが良かったら
ぜひコメントで書いてください
私は捩っなぁ
それならいけますよ最初罰ブーン
じゃんけんパーコラーッ
バーイ
ほかほかもある
ええええええ
me
あっはぁ